The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Then let's go back to
our discussion of what
happens to classical and quantum
mechanical magnetic moments
when they are exposed
to magnetic fields.
I just want to remind you
of what we did last class
and what we want
to wrap up today.
This is rapid adiabatic passage.
I mentioned to you and
explained it to you
that rapid adiabatic
passage is a powerful way
to manipulate a classical
and quantum system,
and what we discussed is that
when a spin points in the up
direction and you
sweep the resonance
of an oscillating magnetic
field-- the frequency
field, through the resonance,
you create an effective magnetic
field in the moving frame which
will rotate.
And the atom, when the
change is done adiabatically,
will follow the rotation and
therefore invert the spin.
So it's a perfect,
very robust method
to invert population
in spin systems.
What I want to pick up
today is the question,
how slow is adiabatic.
We have to fulfill an
adiabatic condition
and we have already
an idea already
of what the adiabatic
condition is
but now we want to derive it.
That we had this
picture of a spin
which is rapidly precessing.
It always precesses
around the direction
of the effective magnetic field,
and the condition adiabadicity
is that the rotation of the
effective magnetic field
has to be much slower
than the precession.
Let me just make it clear
by a counter example.
If the atom precesses
around the magnetic field
and the magnetic field
would suddenly jump,
then the atom would
now start precessing
about the new direction
of the magnetic field
and it would have
completely changed its angle
relative to the magnetic field.
It would have lost its alignment
with the magnetic field.
So you clearly see
that the condition is
the direction of the
magnetic field must not jump,
and the only other time scheme
is the frequency of the Larmor
precession, so our
condition for adiabadicity
is the rotation of the
effective magnetic field
has to be slow compared to
the precession frequency.
And so we want to now
derive from that condition
the conditions for adiabadicity.
And just as an outlook
to make it interesting,
what I will derive for you
in the classical picture
is now something
which you will later
encounter as the
Landau-Zener parameter.
But Landau-Zener sweeps, we
talk about it later today
is a quantum mechanical version
of rapid adiabatic passage,
but we now get
classically a result,
which will feature the
Landau-Zener parameter.
So with that, let us write
down what we want to look at.
It is adiabatic condition,
and to write it down in words
is that the Larmor
frequency, omega L, which
is given by the
effective magnetic field,
has to be much larger
than theta dot.
Now things in general
are rather complicated.
If we are far away
from resonance,
you change the frequency,
but the effective field
is not changing a lot.
The critical moment is really
when we have the real field, we
add the fictitious field
and that cause a rotation.
The critical moment is
when we are near resonance.
So in other words, we have
to fulfill an inequality.
The left side has to be
larger than the right side,
but the left side
is actually smallest
in the vicinity
of the resonance,
and the angle theta
dot is actually
largest near resonance.
That's when it sort of
quickly goes to 90 degrees.
So therefore, if we want to find
the condition of adiabadicity,
we can derive it by
looking at the region
around the resonance.
So the effective magnetic
field is the real field
minus the fictitious
field caused
by the rotation by
the transformation
into the rotating frame.
So we have the magnetic field
at an angle theta with respect
to the z-axis.
I've just written down
the z component for you,
and the transverse component
is-- so this is this component
is the amplitude of our drive
field B1.
So we can just read
it form the diagram.
The resonance data
is 90 degrees,
and the correction
angle is whatever
we have of the effective
z field over B1,
and that means that the
derivative, the angle theta
dot, the angular velocity
at which the magnetic field
rotates, there's a time
derivative because we
sweep the frequency.
So therefore, theta
dot is nothing else
than omega dot, the sweep
rate of the frequency divided
by gamma B1.
But gamma B1 is nothing else
than the Rabi frequency.
And on resonance, the Larmor
frequency is just a Rabi
frequency, because on
resonance-- sorry for repeating
myself-- the fictitious field
has canceled the bias field,
and the only field left
is the rotating field,
but the rotating field
is the Rabi frequency
with a gamma factor.
So therefore, we have
the adiabatic condition
that omega dot
over omega Rabi has
to be smaller than omega Rabi
or to say it inverts the change
delta omega of your
drive frequency,
the change delta omega
in one Ravi period
has to be smaller than
the Rabi frequency.
So omega has units of frequency.
Omega dot is a derivative that's
in units of frequency squared,
and this is to be smaller than
the Rabi frequency squared.
You find that actually
quite often if you
do an adiabatic change
of your trap frequency,
things are adiabatic as long
as the change of the trap
frequency in one period
of the trap frequency
is smaller than
the trap frequency,
and you find something else
that the derivative of your trap
frequency has to be smaller
than the trap frequency squared.
So these are
adiabatic conditions,
when you tighten up magnetic or
optical confinement for atoms.
So this is very, very genetic.
The small rate of the
frequency you change
has to be smaller than the
relevant frequency squared.
As I said, we come
back to that when
we do the quantized treatment
of rapid adiabatic passage
and we encounter
that combination
in the Landau-Zener
parameter, which
takes us to our next topic.
We want to now talk
about quantized spin
in a magnetic field.
And one of the first things
I will be telling you
is that everything
we have learned
about the classical magnetic
moment you don't have
to unlearn or
re-learn, it exactly
applies to the quantum spin.
Before we look at
the Hamiltonian
and the standard Hamiltonian
for two-level system,
let us first look at
something more general, which
is Heisenberg
equations of motion.
So we want to write down
the differential equation,
the equation of motion
for expectation values.
So for an atom in
a magnetic field,
our Hamiltonian is simply
the same Hamiltonian,
which involves the gyromagnetic
ratio, the angular momentum
operator, and the
magnetic field.
And you know from
quantum mechanics
that Heisenberg's equation
of motion for any operator
are simply that the time
derivative of the operator
equals the commutator
with the Hamiltonian.
In some cases, if you have
an explicit time derivative
of the operator,
you have to edit,
but we are talking here
about the angular momentum
operator which has no
explicit time dependents.
So we are interested
in the operator which
describes the magnetic moment,
but the magnetic moment
is nothing else than
the gyromagnetic ratio
times the angular momentum.
So therefore, the
relevant commutator
is the commutator of the
Hamiltonian with the angular
momentum operator.
Just to remind you,
the Hamiltonian
was proportional to z.
So what we are talking about is
commutators, not surprisingly,
between the angular
momentum operators
and those commutators are
just this cyclic commutation
involving the epsilon tensor.
So if you just put that
in component by component,
you realize immediately that the
operator equation for the time
derivative of the
magnetic moment
is nothing else than the cross
product, the vector product,
of the operator of
the magnetic moment
times the magnetic field.
To commence, this is
exact, but also it
looks exactly like
the classical result.
Well, you would say it's
an operator equation.
Usually operator
equation some of them
are pretty useless because you
can't calculate the operators,
but in this case,
we can immediately
take the expectation
value, so we
can get some immediately
meaningfully equation
namely that the
expectation value follows
the same equation,
and this tells us
that whenever we have
a quantum system,
it has a magnetic moment.
In an applied external
magnetic field,
the result is simply rotation,
precession, and this is exact.
It's not a classical
approximation.
It's an exact result
for quantum mechanics.
So the way how we derived
it makes it obvious that
it's an exact result, which is
valid not only for spin-1/2,
but it is valid for any spin.
If you have a magnetic moment
corresponding to a spin of 10 H
bar, this spin follows the same
equation of motion as spin-1/2.
Of course, a special case
is valid for spin-1/2,
but spin-1/2 is isomorphous
to a two-level system.
Any two-level system can be
regarded as spin-1/2 system,
therefore, this geometric
interpretation that
the dynamics of the quantum
system is just a precession
rigorously, exactly applies
to any two-level system.
It's also valid, and this
will be relevant for atoms,
if we have composite
angular momentum.
For instance, we will encounter
the total angular momentum
F of an atom which
has components
from the orbital
motion of the electron,
the spin of the electron,
and the spin of the nucleus.
But if we have such
an angular momentum,
F, the creation of motion
is it will precess around
a magnetic field.
Well the small print here is,
unless the B field is so strong
that it de-couples
the components
or that it breaks up the
coupling of the different parts
of the angular momentum.
In other words, we have
simply assumed here
that magnetic moment is
gamma times angular momentum,
and that requires that
the angular momentum are
coupled in a certain way.
If we don't fully
understand what
coupling of angular
momentum is, we really
talk about that when we
talk about atomic structure.
So as long as the spin state
coupled to one total spin,
this total spin
will just precess.
This picture of
precession will also
be valid for a system
of N two-level systems
coupled to an external
field, and this
will be the example of
Dicke superrradiance, which
we will discussed towards
the end of the course.
So very simple result,
but very powerful,
and this is your
permission whenever
you encounter any of
the systems to see
a vector precessing
in your head.
This is exact.
So we've talked about
Heisenberg equation of motion
for general spin, but--
you have a question, Nancy?
AUDIENCE: What did you mean
by N two-level systems here?
Are we talking about
coherent systems
or non-coherent systems?
PROFESSOR: We talk about
in two-level systems
and to be more specific the
coupling comes because they all
talk to the same magnetic field.
So we have in two-level
systems connected
to the modes of the
electromagnetic field.
We start with the
symmetric state.
The coupling is
symmetric and that
preserves the symmetry
of the atomic state.
In other words, we will have
a situation where the angular
momentum is the maximum
angular momentum we
can get in two-level
system, and the dynamics
of this two-level system,
the description of Dicke
superradiance has the
geometric visualization
of this precessing motion.
I know I'm not
explaining it exactly.
I want to sort of whet your
appetite for what comes later
and also sort of prep you that
some of the simple pictures
will really carry
through the course.
OK, so this is for
very general spin.
Let's now talk about
features of, yes,
the most important spin for us,
namely the two-level system,
which is spin-1/2.
Well, the most generic
system is an electron
in a magnetic field B times ez.
And well, why don't we start
with a clicker question.
So the question is, what
is the level structure
of the electron in
the magnetic field?
It's a two-level system,
and you have two options
A and B. One option is the
upper state is spin up.
The ground state is spin
down or the opposite.
So in other words, and
tell me whether an electron
is in the lower state
when the speed is up
or when the spin is down.
You would say it's
a stupid definition,
but we talk all the
time about an electron
is in the spin down
state or the spin
up state, which is the lower
energy state of the electron.
So I think by exchanging
the better recent number
of responses has
considerably gone up.
OK.
The answer is the electron
is in the ground state.
Spin down is the lowest
state for the electron.
To say it in words, of
course, a compass needle
wants to be aligned
with the magnetic field.
So you want the magnetic
moment to be aligned
with the magnetic
field, and that
means the magnetic
moment has to point
in the plus e direction,
which up but the electron has
negative charge, the
gamma factor is negative,
and that's why for the
electron, the vector of the spin
and the vector of the
magnetic moment are opposite.
So just try to find some
main-mode technical thing.
The electron lives
in the basement.
It wants to be down, spin down.
This is the lowest
state for the electron.
However, if you
have a system which
has a positive gyromagnetic
ratio, which would correspond
to, well, positive charge,
nucleus if it has somewhat
normal magnetic moment, then
in that case, the spin up state
is less energetic than
the spin down state.
So let me just write that down.
So the correct
answer is this one,
and it involves that
gamma is negative.
The gamma is a
gyromagnetic ratio,
the ratio between magnetic
moment and angular momentum,
and for negative
charges, it's negative.
For positive gamma, the
situation is inverted.
So let's just use for
a moment the result
we got from Heisenberg's
equation of motion.
We know the classical result.
We have already derived
for the classic spin,
the classical result
for the expectation
value of the magnetic moment.
But now I want to sort of
relate it to something quantum
mechanical because we know that
the classical solution equals
the quantum mechanical solution.
So if you have a
two-level system,
the z component of
the magnetic moment
is the difference between
spin down and spin up.
And because of conservation
probability, p up and p down
is unity, we can also
write that as 2 times--
let me now introduce
e for excited state,
just I know it's hard to keep
track of spin up, spin down.
I want to make sure that I
mean now the excited state,
so the excited state for
the electron is spin up.
So we have this condition, so
therefore, the excited state
fraction of a two-level system
is related to the expectation
value of the magnetic
moment in that wave,
and now we want to use the
classical result we derived.
We derived the
classical result when
for t equals 0 all the spins
were in the ground state,
and by using the result
we derived previously,
we have the 1/2 from
the previous line
and then the magnetic
moment, mu z.
We found an expression which
involved the Rabi frequency,
and the off resonant
Rabi frequency
are sine square generalized Rabi
frequency times time over 2.
So the two factors
of 1/2 and 1/2
cancel, and what we find now for
the quantum mechanical system
using Heisenberg's
equation of motion
is that if you prepare
a system initially
in the ground state,
the excited state
probability, the fraction,
the excited state oscillates
with a Rabi frequency,
and this is,
I think, the second time in this
course and not the last time
that we see the
Rabi, that we obtain,
the Rabi transition probability.
But let's go further.
We have now discussed
the classical spin.
We have sort of done classical
quantum correspondence
with Heisenberg's
equation of motion.
We know that this in general,
it implies Rabi oscillations,
but now we want to go deeper
into the quantum domain
by talking about the
spin-1/2 Hamiltonian.
So in other words, we want to
go beyond expectation values.
We want to talk about
the wave function itself.
So the Hamiltonian,
which we will
use for major parts
in this course,
it's one of the fundamental
Hamiltonians in physics.
Of course, there's the
harmonic oscillator.
There is a hydrogen
atom, but then there's
this Hamiltonian, which is a
two-level system with splitting
omega naught.
And then we make, which
is often a simplification,
where we use a pure exponential,
so a single frequency
in complex notation where
the complex exponential e
to the i omega t
is the drive term.
So this is one of the
simplest Hamiltonian
for this kind of system.
It's a two-level system with a
splitting, and now it is driven
and the simplest drive term
is not cosine omega t or sine
omega t as we will see.
The simplest drive term
is e to the i omega t.
So this is now our Hamiltonian.
and since it is
so important, let
me ask you a clicker question
whether this Hamiltonian can
be exactly realized in nature
or it is an approximation.
For instance, that you always
have cosine omega t as a drive,
and cosine omega t is
e to the plus i omega t
and e to the minus i omega t.
And then maybe with the
rotating wave approximation,
you throw away a term.
So I sort of wanted
to ask you, is this
an idealization that we
have a coupling which
is a simple, complex
exponential, this nature always
more complicated or
is there a simple way
to realize this
Hamiltonian in nature?
So what do you think?
Stop display.
What's funny about that?
AUDIENCE: Equal to.
AUDIENCE: There are
two [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, they
couldn't make up their mind.
The system should
reject those votes.
Anyway, it means most of
you anticipate what I want
to derive to you that we can
actually exactly get this
Hamiltonian and indeed, this is
the Hamiltonian I will derive
for you in the next few minutes,
which is the Hamiltonian
of spin-1/2 in a magnetic field
coupled to a rotating magnetic
field.
So we start out
with fields which
are real, real field,
no imaginary numbers,
no complex numbers.
These are real fields, but
when we write down how the real
fields couple to spin-1/2, we
get e to the i omega t and e
to the minus omega t
without any approximation.
So since at least 80%
of you know the result,
just regard it as an exercise to
introduce how we spin matrices
in a nice way, also
this will help you
how to do pre-set number 1.
So the Hamiltonian is the spin
coupled to a magnetic field,
and if we express that by
angular momentum operators,
the gyromagnetic ratio
it involves the operator
for the spin in the z direction.
So the two-level system has
a splitting of H bar omega,
so it's plus 1/2
minus 1/2 H bar omega,
and that means
the diagonal part,
the non-driven part is simply
given by the Pauli spin matrix
sigma z and omega naught
is the energy splitting,
which is proportional to
the applied magnetic field.
And up-down, and
excited and ground
are the eigenstates of this
Hamiltonian with energies
plus minus H bar
omega naught over 2.
So this is the same Hamiltonian,
but now add a real rotating B
field B1.
So the drive Hamiltonian H1
is the same magnetic moment
but now coupled to a
time-dependent rotating field.
The amplitude of
the rotating field
is the Rabi frequency
divided by gamma,
and we assume that the field
is rotating in the xy plane.
So it's ex ey cosine
omega t sine omega t.
And now I put in two minus
signs here for convenience.
If you want, I've just shifted--
it's just a definition.
I've changed the definition of
the amplitude by a minus sign.
So this is the Rabi frequency,
and the magnetic moment
divided by gamma is
nothing than the spin.
Magnetic moment is
gamma times the spin,
so therefore, we are back
to the spin operators
and the spin operators,
if I factor out 1/2 H bar,
are now the Pauli spin
matrices sigma x and sigma y.
And if you look at
those spin matrices,
then you'll realize that we
go complex in our Hamiltonian,
not because we have approximated
a real field cosine omega
t by some e to the i
omega t, but because when
we have a rotating field and
we write down it in Pauli spin
matrices, we get imaginary units
form the sigma y spin matrix.
So that means we have
now for this system
rewritten the coupling term took
you to the rotating field H1
as 0 0 e to the plus i omega
t e to the minus i omega t.
And therefore,
the Hamiltonian is
the famous two-level
Hamiltonian with omega naught
and the Rabi frequency,
which I wrote down
at the beginning
of this chapter.
So we'll leave that here, but we
will use it even more in 8.421.
This is the famous
dressed atom Hamiltonian.
It is the starting point
to calculate eigenstates
and eigenvalues, not just
in perturbation theory.
You can go to oscillating
fields at arbitrary strengths,
so you can solve exactly in
the dressed atom picture using
this Hamiltonian, the
problem of a two-level system
plus one mode of the
electromagnetic field
no matter what the
drive term, what
the strengths of the
electromagnetic field
in the spin mode is.
So this describes
the two-level system
plus one mode of the
electromagnetic field
with arbitrary strengths.
And as I said, we talk
about some things here
but others I explored in 8.422.
Questions?
Yes, Will.
AUDIENCE: We refer to the
eigenstates and eigenenergies
of this Hamiltonian as dressed
in states in the same way
as we refer to address states
in a fully quantized fiction?
Do we refer to both
cases as dressed states?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's a good question.
The question is now, what are
the dressed states, and Will,
I think you are
referring that there
are two ways to talk about the
coupling of a two-level system
to one mode of the
electromagnetic field.
It is this same
classical picture
where we introduce and let
me say an analog amplitude
of the electromagnetic
field which drives it.
And then there is a
fully quantized picture
where you first quantize
electromagnetic field
and you couple to
photon number states.
Actually the beauty of
it that the two solutions
are exactly the same.
So in other words, how to
say, if you couple an atom
to one mode of the
electromagnetic field.
We have two ways
how we can solve it.
One is, we introduce a
coherent electromagnetic field,
and there is an exact unitary
transformation which tells us
if we have the quantized
field in a coherent state,
we can do unitary
transformation,
and what we get is
exactly this Hamiltonian.
So therefore, this is also--
you may not recognize it--
this is actually the
quantum description
of the electromagnetic field
when it is in a coherent state.
The other option is, we use
the dressed atom picture maybe
following some work of
[INAUDIBLE] and others
where we assume this single
mode of electromagnetic field
has in photons, and
then we solve it
for this photon number state.
So in other words,
these are the two ways
how we can relatively,
easily treat the problem.
Either we assume the quantum
field is in a coherence state
or it's in a flux state.
But since the dressed atom
picture in the standard way
assumes that the photon
number, N, is large,
there is a correspondence
that in the limit of N of N
being large, the flux
state description
and the coherent state
description fully agree.
And you pick what you want.
If you introduce the
electromagnetic field
explicitly with
it's quantum state,
you get the dressed atom
picture as a solution of a time
independent problem, whereas
here with a coherent state
description, the coherent state
oscillates, cosine omega t,
with a time-dependent problem.
And actually I
should say whenever
I get confused in one picture,
I look in the other picture
and it becomes clear.
I generally prefer
where we have N photons,
it's because we can
discuss everything
in a time-independent way, but
for certain intuitive aspects,
this is also variable, so in
the end, you have to learn both.
And in your homework,
you will actually
write down the general
solution for this Hamiltonian
as an exercise.
Nancy.
AUDIENCE: I think I'm
confused a little bit.
So in the flux state
picture, the dressed states
can be exactly part of an
independent matter of coupling
between a lesser photon
on any excited state.
So like we can write eN as 1
and g or something like that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You couple a photon field
with N photons and energy
in H bar omega to N
minus 1 H bar omega.
AUDIENCE: But in this one,
is there like a direct photon
number thing, because we
haven't quantized the field yet?
So what do the dressed
states mean at this point?
PROFESSOR: Well, the fact
is that if you start out
with a coherent state, your
photon field is not in photons,
it's a laser beam.
The laser beam or
the coherent state
is in a quantized description,
a superposition of many flux
states.
So therefore, the number of
photons in a coherent state
fluctuates or has a large
Plutonian statistics,
and if you take one
photon out or not,
it doesn't make
a big difference.
For instance, for
those of you who
know how the coherent
state is state defined,
the coherent state
is defined as when
you act on the coherent state
with an annihilation operator,
you get the eigenvalue
times the coherent state.
So that tells you you have a
fully-quantized description
of your laser in terms
of a coherent state.
You take one photon
out and what you get?
the same state back.
And this may immediately justify
that what we write down here
is simply the coherent
state with its amplitude
and the amplitude of
the coherent state
would be B1, the amplitude
of the drive field.
And we don't really
need other states
because a coherent
state has the property.
You to take a photon out and
you still have the same state.
So therefore, we
don't have to keep
track of the coherent state.
It's there all the time.
But what I'm saying
can be formulated
more exactly when we use
the appropriate formulas.
But this is sort of the bridge.
That's why we do not have to
keep track of the photon state.
It's because the coherent state
has those wonderful properties.
Other questions?
OK.
So this is the
famous Hamiltonian.
And of course, if it's
the famous Hamiltonian,
we want to solve it.
As I said, the general solution
is left to the homework,
but I want to sort
of show you parts
of the solution to tell a story.
And the question is, well, how
do we solve this Hamiltonian?
The answer is, we
do exactly what we
did in the classical problem.
We transform to
the rotating frame.
In other words, this
Hamiltonian is best
solved by doing-- you can
actually solve it directly.
You can just put in a tri
wave function and solve it.
But I want to sort of
bring out the big idea here
which is analogous
to what we have done
in the last few
classes, namely we
have involved rotating frames.
So what solves this Hamiltonian
is a unitary transformation,
and the unitary
transformation is this one.
And so this unitary
transformation,
let me first write it down,
it transforms the Hamiltonian
to the time independent one.
We have now time independent
of diagonal matrix elements.
Our diagonal matrix
element have changed.
Delta is now the detuning of the
tri frequency from the energy
splitting of the
two-level system.
In particular, when
we are on resonance,
the diagonal matrix
elements have disappeared.
This is the result of the
unitary transformation,
and let me just show you this
transformation over here.
Can be actually written
as an operator involving
the z component of
the magnetic field.
And what I just wrote
down for you is actually
the quantum mechanical
operator, the rotation
operator for performing at
rotation around the z-axis.
So by selecting the rotation
angle to be omega t,
that's how I can generate
the unitary transformation,
and this unitary transformation
makes the Hamiltonian time
independent.
So in other words, everything
is in the classical system.
We just go to a frame which
rotates with a [INAUDIBLE],
and we find the
time-independent problem.
So now this Hamiltonian
can be easily solved.
And you will find
as a special case
when you start
with an amplitude,
initially you start
in the ground state,
then the excited
state amplitude square
is the Rabi
oscillation, something
we discussed 40 minutes
ago, but before, we
got it from the
classical quantum
mechanical correspondence
using the Heisenberg equation
of motion and here it comes
out by explicitly solving
for the wave function for
the dressed Hamiltonian.
Questions?
I want to say a few words now
about rapid adiabatic passage,
but this time by emphasizing
the quantum mechanical aspects.
In other words, we have
a clear understanding
what happens classically.
We have a clear
understanding what
happens in the adiabatic
limit, but I just
want to sort of in
the next 10 minutes
use what we have
already learned,
combine it with the quantum
mechanical Hamiltonian
and tell you that, well, when
you are not fully adiabatic,
you actually have transition
probabilities between the two
states.
So I want to sort of bring
in the concept of transition
probabilities to
the case of-- what
I want to say is rapid
adiabatic passage when it's
no longer adiabatic, but what
this just means when we sweep
the frequency and we're
not in the adiabatic limit.
So how do we describe
it quantum mechanically?
We start out with a Hamiltonian,
which has-- we use our rotating
framework for convenience
that allows to write down
exactly the same Hamiltonian
in time-independent picture.
So the Hamiltonian has
two parts, a diagonal part
and an off-diagonal part.
So if I show the energy as a
function of detuning delta--
well, maybe I should
times 2 over H bar,
just normalize it so then it
becomes just the straight line
at 45 degree y equals x.
So the unperturbed-- the
Hamiltonian without drive
has a level crossing
at detuning 0.
Then we add to it
the drive term.
Well, let me just
write down, not
the drive term but
the full Hamiltonian.
So the full Hamiltonian with
the addition of the drive term
has delta minus
delta and now it has
the coupling with
the Rabi frequency.
That means that on resonance,
the degeneracy between the two
levels is split by
the Rabi frequency,
and if I now show
you the energy eigen
levels of this
two-by-two Hamiltonian,
it will asymptotically
coincide with a dashed line
through this and through that.
So in other words,
I'm just reminding you
that a non-diagonal matrix
element turns a crossing
into an avoided crossing.
So when we take
the frequency omega
and we sweep the detuning,
so we change delta
and do a sweep of the frequency
omega at a rate omega dot,
then we sweep through the
resonance and in one limit,
we have rapid adiabatic
passage or in general, we
realize the Landau-Zener
problem of a sweep
through an avoided crossing.
So what I'm formulating
here is it's
the so-called
Landau-Zener crossing
or the Landau-Zener
problem, which
is the quantum mechanical
description of you take
a system by changing
an external parameter.
Here, we sweep the frequency
of the rotating field,
but by changing the
external parameter,
we sweep the system through
the avoided crossing.
And it has the
two limiting cases
that when we go through this
crossing very, very slowly,
the adiabatic field
then tells us we
stay on one of these
adiabatic solid curves,
and this is the case of rapid
adiabatic passage, which
we discuss in the
classical limit.
But it is also
the other solution
if you would sweep through
it very, very fast,
you're in the diabatic limit,
you follow the dashed line
and you start up here
and you wind up there.
The Landau-Zener
problem is actually
a problem which you find
it in all it text books,
but to the best of
my knowledge, there
is no simple,
elementary derivation
which I could give
you in a few minutes.
And if the
mathematical problem is
a nice, mathematical
demonstration
of an exact, solvable model,
but to my knowledge explicitly
deriving it is not providing
additional insight.
It's one of the cases
where the result is
more insightful and much
simpler than the derivation.
So what I want to give
you is, therefore,
simply the textbook result.
So in the adiabatic limit,
you stay on the solid line.
If you do not cross the avoided
crossing very, very slowly,
you'll have a
non-adiabatic probability
to jump from one level
to the other one.
And this non-adiabatic
probability
is expressed as an
exponential function which
involves the
Landau-Zener parameter.
And the Landau-Zener parameter
in this exact solution
is omega Rabi squared times
this new rate, d omega
dt or d delta dt minus 1.
This square should go
outside the brackets,
so therefore, what we find
is from the exact solution
that the Landau-Zener
parameter is a quarter times--
and this should
now look familiar,
the omega Ravi frequencies
squared over omega dot.
And when we discussed the limit
of adiabaticity classically,
I hope you remember I gave
you the argument by looking
at the adiabatic condition that
the adiabatic case requires
omega dot to be much smaller
than omega Rabi squared.
So here very naturally
what appears in the quantum
mechanical problem is just the
ratio of the two quantities
we compared when we looked
for the limit of adiabaticity.
So therefore, the probability
for a non-adiabatic transition
is simply involving this
ratio omega Rabi squared
over omega dot.
So in other words,
we know already
from the classical
argument, but here we
confirm it, adiabaticity require
that this inequality is met.
OK, I could stop
here, but since we
are using sort of diabatic
sweeps in the laboratory,
as long as I've been involved
in doing quote "atom science,"
I want to sort of go one
step further and teach you
a little bit more
about this formula
and try to provide
insight, and often
insight is also provided when
you apply perturbation theory.
So I know the adiabatic
case is very simple,
but I want to look
at the diabatic case
and then look at
transition probabilities
in a perturbative way.
This is actually the way how
we often transfer population
in the laboratory.
So I want to understand
better the way how we transfer
population from one
curve to the other one.
So if we do a fast sweep,
we call it diabatic.
So in other words, if
we have this crossing
and we go really fast,
well, what happens
is this is the crossing
between spin up and spin down.
If you go much, much faster
than the Rabi frequency,
the spin has no opportunity
to change its orientation.
So therefore, the wave function,
the spin has to stay up or down
and that means the
system just goes straight
through the crossing.
Because spin up has
positive slopes,
spin down has negative slope.
Being adiabatic, staying on
this lower adiabatic curve
would actually
require the system
to go from spin up in this
part of the adiabatic curve
to spin down in the other part.
And to flip a spin cannot
be done faster than the Rabi
frequency, so if you sweep
fast, that's what's happening.
So we have two trivial limits,
one is the adiabatic limit
or just the adiabatic
curve and nothing happens.
The other limit is the
infinitely-fast limit
and nothing happens
again when we
look at the diabatic basis,
which is spin up and spin down.
But now let's be
almost adiabatic,
and this is a problem
which we really
want to understand physically
and intuitively because that
means the system spins the
small timelier resonance,
and there is a small probability
to make a transition.
So if you had one of
your hyperfine states,
pick your favorite
hyperfine state,
you'll rapidly
sweep the frequency.
You will find, unless you
sweep it infinitely fast
that there's a small probability
in the other hyperfine state.
And that's what you
want to calculate now,
and I want you to
understand how would you
estimate and calculate
the small probability.
So let's now estimate
the result, namely
for the small probability
in perturbation theory.
And actually what I'm
calculating for you here is,
if you've used evaporation--
I know half of the class
is doing that-- if you
apply an i F field,
you don't have to
make it so strong
that you and the
adiabatic limit.
You are exactly in this limit.
The atom will
slosh several times
through the resonance in
an almost diabatic way,
but there is a finite
spin flip probability
and that's how you
evaporate atoms.
And I want you now
to fully understand
the derivation, what is the
probability of ejecting atoms
in the almost diabatic
limit with i F spin flips.
That's a limit where 90% of
the BEC experiments operate.
So I hope everyone realize
it's an important question
and also I hope
everybody understands
the question because now I
have bigger questions for you.
The first question
which I will ask you,
should we calculate that
transition probability
by using perturbation theory
for an incoherent transition
or for coherent transition?
Let me just explain you
what I mean and then I
ask you for your opinion.
Coherently, we simply say
in perturbation theory,
we start with our
population in state 1.
We have to do the
coupling Hamiltonian time
dependence of the
population in state 2
and that means if we integrate
this equation for a short time,
we find an amplitude a2.
And the probability
to be in the state
2, which is the
amplitude squared,
is proportional to the
Rabi frequency squared
times the effective
time squared,
the effective time of
tribing the system.
Coherent processes are
always quadratic in time.
If we do it incoherently,
well, the way
how we describe
incoherent processes
are Fermi's golden rule,
which we've all seen.
And the probability in Fermi's
golden rule is very different.
Well, it is proportional to
the Rabi frequency squared,
to the matrix element squared,
but Fermi's golden rule
gives us a constant rate,
and for constant rate,
the probability is
rate times time.
So now it is linear
in time and then
because of the delta function
in Fermi's golden rule--
I'm missing a symbol
so I use gamma here.
It has nothing to do with
the Landau-Zener probability.
This is just the
density of states.
So I hope you know now
what is the difference
between coherent or incoherent.
The most important
part is that things
are linear in time for an
incoherent pulses rate equation
and at least for small
times quadratic in time
for coherent pulses.
So now we come to
this process where
we take atoms from
spin up to spin down.
We evaporate with a weak,
course, almost adiabatic
with weaker f drive, so we are
closer to the diabatic limit.
And so if you think
about this problem,
I want you to tell
me if this process,
the perturbative transition
close to the diabatic case
is that should we use
when we apply perturbation
theory, the coherent picture
or the incoherent picture.
In other words, is the dynamics
of the quantum system, when
we go relatively quickly for
the Landau-Zener crossing,
is that a coherent or
an incoherent process?
I could see where it doesn't
matter, but it does matter.
So I think it's
an open question.
Let me give you the answer.
It is coherent, and you can
see it in the following way.
What is the source
of incoherent here?
We have a Hamiltonian.
The Hilbert space
is by two-by-two.
There is no coherence
which can be lost.
There is no spontaneous
emission to other states.
There is no reservoir.
We don't have a small system
which couples to a bigger
system, and then
the small system--
we do that on Wednesday--
has to-- tomorrow,
Wednesday-- has to be
described by density matrix.
We have the none of
the physics which
would give arise to
incoherent physics.
It is coherent.
But maybe I'm oversimplifying.
Is somebody who
said it's incoherent
who wants to maybe press
me harder and tell me
why you think it is incoherent.
Well, one possibility
is-- and this
is why we often use
Landau-Zener sweeps in the lab.
We have fluctuations of
the resonance frequency.
And when we go and
sweep through it,
we don't know exactly
when we hit the resonance.
And if you would take
an ensemble of systems
and you go through the
resonance at different times,
you will get an ensemble
of wave functions, which
has different phase factors
in it, and in the end,
you will actually need a
density matrix to describe it.
But this is now an
experimental imperfection
which I haven't assumed here.
So in other words, what you
should do is the following.
Whenever you sweep through
Landau-Zener crossing,
you start with the ground
state and what you get out
is a superposition of
ground and excited state.
And the Hamiltonian determines
absolutely every aspect
of the amplitude in the ground
and the excited state including
all phase factors.
In other words, if you do a
Landau-Zener crossing in a way
that you prepare
50-50% of the atoms,
they are always face coherent
and you can use this process
as a beam splitter in
an atomic thermometer.
Fully coherent.
We have five minutes,
so if we assume now,
I hope we all agree that
the amplitude is obtained
in this coherent wave, then,
of course, the question is,
but what is the effective time?
When we sweep the
resonance, we are far away.
Nothing happens.
We go through the resonance,
everything happens.
Nothing happens.
So this is the effective time
when the wave function really
changes and we create
the coherent and mixture
in the second state.
And it is this
effective times squared
which determines what
happens, what our transmission
amplitude is.
So therefore, the
question is, what
is the effective time in
the Landau-Zener crossing?
I can give you three choices.
One is, the effective time
is, well, we change omega
and the effective time
is, how long, what
is the time until we
have a detuning, which
is equal to the Rabi frequency.
Another possibility is that
the effective time where
we coherently
drive the system is
1 over the Rabi frequency,
just the Rabi period.
Or another choice, how
I can construct time out
of the two frequencies where
it's omega Rabi and omega dot.
These are our two elements.
So another possibility
how I can get time
is, omega dot is
frequency squared,
and the square root of 1
over omega dot at least
fulfills the dimensional
criterion that this is time.
So my question for you
is, what do you think
is the effective
time during which
we drive the system coherently?
I have to tell you before
I made up the problem,
I do not know the answer.
But I can also
tell you that there
is only one answer
which is correct.
All right.
I have to say I expected A
to be the correct answer,
but I convinced
myself it's only B.
And the answer is the following,
and I know I have to stop,
but I only need
three more lines.
The effective time is not the
time until you are detuned,
the effective time is which
I can call the dephasing
time, the time during which
everything is coherent.
What happens is, we change
the frequency delta omega,
and the delta omega
is, of course,
omega dot times delta t.
So if we change the frequency
by sweeping it in such a way
that we are detuning and
now with that detuning,
if we let the system evolve, we
would get a phase shift of pi.
That's sort of the maximum where
everything adds up coherently.
If we would go longer
in time, the frequency
has changed to the
point that what
we add to the amplitude
of the other state
is no longer in phase to
what we have added before.
You can sort of look
at it like this.
You have a little bit of
phase a2, You build up.
You build up.
You build up by adding
amplitude with the same phase.
But now you are
sweeping, and this
is the criterion where
you start to pile up
things with the
wrong phase and then
the phase eventually
becomes randomized
and you're not
effectively contributing.
This equation defines
the window delta
t during which we effectively
add substantial amplitude
in the second state, and it
involves delta t squared,
so neglecting factors of
unity, the result of this
is that, indeed, delta t
is 1 over omega dot plus.
And indeed, if we say the
probability for coherent drive
is Rabi frequency squared times
delta t squared, what we now
obtain is the Rabi frequency
squared over omega dot,
and this is our
Landau-Zener parameter.
So in other words, if we
check with the exact result,
the Landau-Zener probability,
1 minus p non-adiabatic--
the Landau-Zener problem
is e to the minus 2 pi
over gamma or gamma pi over
2 over the Landau-Zener
parameter, if I do an expansion
of the Landau-Zener parameter
for a small value
of the exponent,
the exact result is
2 pi times gamma,
and this is indeed proportional
to omega Rabi squared
over omega dot.
So in other words,
what I've shown
you is that coherent
time evolution
with this weird effective time,
what I motivated physically,
exactly that produce
the limit of small gamma
from the exact result for
the Landau-Zener crossing.
OK.
I know time is over.
Any questions?
OK.
So today was officially
our Monday class,
so we meet again tomorrow,
the same place, the same time.